alors là chabat et gérard darmon ce film
va être un énorme succès vous ne m'en
voudrez pas de vous faire une interview
à nous porter la catastrophe
[Applaudissements]
alain chabat
le jour même de votre mariage
vous avez le coup de foudre pour une
autre c'est réciproque
vous faites quoi
à
compliqué c'est compliqué je suis très
lâche je dis oui mon amour
on n'est pas à l'abri d'une catastrophe
donc le jour du mariage coup de foudre
pour une autre série 6-3 vous faites
quoi c'est pas ça vous est déjà arrivé
peut-être en fait jour merci de m'aider
je sais pas je pense que moi j'aime bien
les choses quand elles arrivent à moi je
sais pas si c'est une chose qui peut
être fait une médiatement je le fais
jouer après c'est vraiment un coup de
foudre placard oui ne change pas
alors vous êtes
en vacances avec toute votre famille
vous retrouvez seul avec votre
belle-mère qui vous fait des avances en
forme
c'est d'après midi tout le monde est à
la mer vous êtes seul avec mamie givet
à moins d'une mois ce sans aucune
hésitation j'y vais aussi l'alcool y est
c'est bon à savoir
oui votre femme
en ce cas là tous les chiffres du loto
mais vous avez oublié de valider le
bulletin ah ouais on lui dit ça comment
moi je dis gagner du temps ouais c'est
ça qui est important pour ça c'est
gagner du temps les vignes et qu'est ce
que vous faites
justement je lui dit donne moi le
le billet que toi que tu as couché c'est
toi qui n'as rien tu comprends pourquoi
on s'est jamais mariée c'est tout alors
vous avez draguer une nana super bon
super ça c'est vrai je suis témoin vous
la ramenez chez vous vous découvrez que
c'est un travesti vous réagissez comme
antar est pas arrivé mais
pourquoi tu ne peux pas être votre
peuple ok je la refais oui ça m'est
arrivé
bully ray
pas de problème il faut aimer les femmes
avec des grands clitoris mots je suis
d'accord
est ce que votre père regarde l'émission
là dans la royale c'est comme si des
gros mots et quand je me moque des
faibles
voilà une raison il a raison à mort
reçues la raison d'un gros clitoris est
pas un gros bof c'est donc ça passe
voilà c'est même un nom égyptien gros
qui tories donc ça reste dans la mission
cléopâtre c'est la promo voilà cela fait
de la promo papa ouais mon père pour moi
il est juste toujours à l'école il dit
comment ça va bien claude berri il est
content de ton travail vers lescure il
trouve que tu travailles bien mais c'est
mon fan numéro 000 et quand même c'est
lui que j'ai vu à burger quiz
directement avec le père de fer rogers
way avec le papa de farouches alors
attention interview catastrophe contrôle
de routine sur la route pendant que les
flics inspectent le véhicule votre pote
était assis à côté de vous vous avoue
qu'il transporte 1 kg de cocaïne dans
son sac
vous l'avez pas dit bien sûr n'est sûr
fait quoi
couvent mais après on partage
ça s'est pas passé comme ça je sais où
est ce que je fais n'est tombée d'un
coup il a fait un film derrière
de quoi c'est à dire quoi que j'ai pas
compris dans une bagnole oui d'accord là
je comprends le pote avec qui vous êtes
je suis aussi là au moment où les flics
arrivent
j'ai un kg de coke dans le sac oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait faites quoi vous me
dites à tête est un gros con va essayer
de s'en sortir le ceva ont baissé de 2,2
le passé ce sont le ch est après voilà
donc les
59e ont fait notre logique ça serait
vraiment pour la banane ou bercy
votre fils vous annonce qu'il va se
marier 88 ça m'étonnerait beaucoup
toujours situé de l'esprit oui la jeune
fille s'appelle ben laden ammonites quoi
vas-y nicklas
pour sauver la population d'une ville
vous êtes bruce willis pour sauver la
population d'une ville je vais faire
sauter un train yes
si votre femme et vos enfants sont à
bord alors
fait quoi désolé pour les villes ça va
pas être possible il va sauter je suis
désolé alain chabat interview
catastrophe
vous partez en vacances à l'île maurice
et rigolade c'est bien
le 30 janvier les corrections de ne rien
rater de l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus